shot clock is down to sex thought maker  is head to Rosenbaum attention Oh hard  7-nothing run by Toronto I don't  disagree with you jacket  DeRozan with the throw down to the  rafters looking like the Raptor nasty  [Applause]  Oh  rosin flying high the fins  [Applause]  then swims it  we never saw the commad and DeRozan with  the vicious landing some of the shots  [Applause]  the rosin season opening drives it all  the down the bar DeRozan with her slam  as soon as he saw that daylight he  this is a credible move the Rosen drives  by  [Applause]  Wow  [Applause]  since I said take him  BB DeMar DeRozan DeRozan throws down a  vicious and nasty slam  [Applause]  you're talking about  he took it in his grill and screwed up  Toronto a sign of early Denver  [Applause]  the Martha Rose in six ago  [Music]  [Applause]  under tort that's what an all-star looks  like folks and this is what he's been  doing all year long  this is just been an incredible play